Chelsea is here with me hi Kelsey it's
good to see you lovely to see you I'm
okay how are you I'm good thanks tell me
about the football match so I decided
last year for me obviously we just lost
Tom Father's Day I just couldn't
actually even think about
um but this year I was like I want to
celebrate him and for the kids to
celebrate him so I planned a charity
football match and yeah it's just
exceeded my expectations completely tell
me more about it so we've got lots of
celebrities that are coming down to play
football on Sunday at Bromley FC we've
got Harry jard from McFly we've got Ryan
Thomas and we've got Ben Cohen we've got
lots and lots of stars some love Island
Stars some tick tockers
um but yeah it's going to be an amazing
day and it's going to be a really like
family fun day as well we've got Elsa
and Anna coming along and Spider-Man and
so we've got face painting I mean it's
about everyone it's not just about now
where is it at what time how do people
get involved can they come and watch
everyone can come and watch you can if
you go through my Instagram you can get
tickets
um on there and at the moment we've
actually sold over 2 000 tickets amazing
and it's all going to ahead of the game
which is a brain tumor charity which I
support
tell me how the last year has been
do you know what it's been it's been
tough
but then also we've had happy moments
you know I've got two kids
um Bodie and irelia who are two and
three so their names on your own yeah
yeah my babies yeah
um yeah it's been really really tough
for us
um but then we've had happy we're gonna
have happy moments like this to
celebrate Tom you know
yes it is it has been tough but there's
that we need to take their moments to
celebrate yeah what advice would you
give um to people who might find
themselves in a similar position to the
family where do they go who do they talk
to how do they look after themselves and
their loved ones do you know for me I
always say take each day as it comes
because grief is a roller coaster and
you know you're not just gonna ever wake
up one day and go oh I'm okay because
that's that's just not life is it
um you know there's so many Charities
that are set up that you can go and see
bereavement Charities
um there's a charity called way which is
like widowed and young
um who I met up with there's there's so
much support out there and if you feel
like you need that support then go and
seek the advice and and help
um and as far as raising funds is
concerned you're hoping to raise a lot
of money as well obviously aren't you
for this Charity tell me what the
charity does so um ahead of the game
supports you whilst you're in trade
treatment so
um if you're if you've got a brain tumor
and you're undergoing chemo and radio it
helps with alternative therapies which
you know there's so there's such there's
such lack of funding in the NHS so you
need like Physio and um Dave Bolton he's
actually a 10-year Survivor of
glioblastoma who I run the charity with
and he has an oxygen
um oxygen therapy there he has red light
therapy he actually builds programs for
you to do like physiotherapy there's so
much that we're giving to people that
the NHS can't support with and
everything we need to know is on your
Instagram Kelsey yes fantastic it's good
to see you thanks very much appreciate
it